try something with me put your thumb up
and point at it with your index finger
like this
Anna
now try to switch them back and forth
[Music]
how are you doing
I'm doing okay but it's also my 19th
take uh this is an example of what you
call bi-manual interference which is the
challenge that your brain encounters
when both hands are trying to do
difficult tasks
next to me is a man whose mind and body
have led him to accomplish incredible
things he's a Super Bowl champion Super
Bowl MVP of the NFL's all-time leader in
passing it out to completion his New
Orleans Saints quarterback Drew Brees
Michael King and you're watching brain
games
[Applause]
this episode is all about the brains of
the everyday superhumans who live and
walk among us their Superior perception
decision-making and spatial awareness
and the technological and psychological
hacks we Mortals might use to compete
with them Drew in your experience what
does a high-level NFL quarterback have
to have up here to succeed you have to
really order the chaos that is going on
around you right there's all kinds of
craziness you've got free rushers you've
got things that are breaking down at the
end of the day how can you make very
quick decisions that are very good
decisions that avoid mistakes and keep
you moving the ball down the field to go
score points order the chaos order the
chaos okay one way Drew's brain is
likely different than mine or yours is
how quickly he can make those decisions
luckily for us scientists have developed
a test for that which we've used as the
basis of our next experiment raft day
[Applause]
this challenge tests Drew's cognitive
flexibility our brain's ability to
quickly shift from one concept to
another
[Music]
here's how this works
hidden over there and those frames are
three pairs of jerseys when this light
turns green two of the jerseys will
light up and Drew will need to use his
lightning quick decision-making skills
to hit the correct one with a football
according to a simple but slightly
tricky rule so Drew if they're both red
jerseys that light up then you need to
hit the higher numbered Jersey if their
blue jerseys you need to hit the lower
numbered Jersey okay
okay so for instance these jerseys are
red the numbers are 19 and 10. uh so
you're gonna hit the Higher One
if you've got this
come on Keegan here we go oh come on
bring it down you bring it down four
bring it down
just bring it down four bring it down
bring it down yeah oh
[Applause]
Summit tries
seven trucks
[Applause]
don't tell anybody
guys it's just us but we'll just edit
out the first seven
so when you're done you hit this button
to lock in your time got it we ran this
with a crowd of NFL fans and couch
potatoes and they averaged 4.4 seconds
per correct throw so who thinks uh that
Drew is gonna smoke this thing
yeah me too
and you're ready for this ready all
right let's assume the position
[Applause]
red high blue low got it come back hit
that button any second the light's gonna
turn green
oh I guess
[Applause]
what do you got huh it's the time
okay huh okay here we go
3.2 seconds oh 3.2 seconds oh I love it
I love the Competitive Edge oh that's it
we can beat that turn back around all
right okay and we are going to play it
again this time with four jerseys so
you're going to have to make two choices
all right I'll get two balls
got it got it okay the light will turn
green at any time okay
[Music]
[Applause]
that is like so satisfying
amazing did it again 5.8 the average
person they only did one of them in 4.4
seconds so if you double that that's 8.8
he did it in 5.8 three extra seconds
better so I just want to say it's
incredible it's really incredible
for the last round we're gonna change
the rules okay three footballs this time
you're gonna see all three pairs of
jerseys if they're red
pick the larger font larger font if
they're blue
pick the even number okay free footballs
you ready got it all right so we have
you stand the thing I'm gonna load up
this button will turn green at any
moment
okay
even
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
it's tough
this is the toughest thing anybody's
ever had to do on brain games
by the way the toughest thing ever good
enough uh and by the way here's
something you might be familiar with we
have a replay we have a replay replay we
got a little replay right here yep oh
look at that look at that intensity
[Applause]
it's good
so as expected Drew destroyed that
challenge uh here with the science
actually you know what Drew you want to
take a stab at this yeah sure
reacting quickly to a change in the
rules is made possible by something
called cognitive flexibility a way in
which our brain achieves its goals by
juggling several mental processes at
once this takes place in the frontal
lobe frontal lobe frontal lobe yep with
the help of multiple neuronal
connections from other brain regions
it's kind of like the control tower for
your whole body and you'd expect a high
level of cognitive flexibility in an NFL
legend like Drew Brees really
[Applause]
give yourself some credits
[Applause]
[Music]
outstanding spatial recognition is
essential for a successful athlete but
sometimes our eyes and brains deceive us
here are two photos of 50 yard lights
which do you think angles the most
I think it's the image on the right but
they are actually identical photos our
brains treat the two images as if they
were part of a single scene that and the
low angle causes us to confuse the
perspective of the lines
so Drew
you you clearly work out your body do
you also work out your mind yes
absolutely even more so than the body uh
to prepare for a game takes so many
mental reps just over and over again wow
and actually perform you know how you
would perform on game day over and over
in your mind so that when you do get out
there on game day it's as if the game's
already been won interesting interesting
we explored a brain Hack That Could up
anyone's game welcome brain games roving
neuroscientist Kara Santa Maria
h
so Kara tell us about your latest
Adventure yeah so I wanted to try out an
experimental technique that's meant to
help you improve your performance and we
decided to try it out with a bunch of
basketball players okay let's take a
look all right
[Music]
all right
all right guys we're gonna see if you
can improve one of the most measurable
parts of your game the vertical lead a
player's vertical leap is the distance
between their standing reach that's the
top of their fingertips when they
stretch their arms High and the Apex of
their standing jump we'll take the best
of their three jumps as their Baseline
Xavier you want to demonstrate yeah
let's do it okay cool
[Music]
red eight
seven
dang dude
[Music]
we're going to test the effects of
transcranial direct current stimulation
or tdcs on this group of athletes
tdcs is a technique that uses
electricity to stimulate the brain
alright guys so this looks just kind of
like a normal pair of headphones but it
actually does a lot more than that they
stimulate your motor cortex so that's a
part of your brain that's responsible
for motor movement if you stimulate your
brain enough these zaps will actually
help improve the kind of connections
between your neurons and eventually the
skill that you're practicing with the
headset on you'll be better at it we
gave six of our players a training
regimen specifically designed to
increase their vertical leak they're
going to wear the headsets for 20
minutes a day and then train what do you
think
snow some players are wearing Placebo
headsets that don't deliver a current
we'll see whether or not transcranial
direct current stimulation improves
performance
[Music]
so Xavier now I want to see if those
results paid off all right let's do it
okay cool cool
all right so it looks like we got red 11
which is the second from the very top of
those with functioning headsets Xavier
got a nine percent increase
raise a bumped hers up by eight percent
and Caroline boosted hers by seven
percent yell was wearing the placebo
headset and had no change in her jump
[Music]
I did it a couple times two times a week
yeah so you improved like a lot the
experimental group improved their
vertical leap by an average of 7.94
although there were a lot of factors at
play those wearing the active headsets
did seem noticeable Improvement and
among Elite athletes even a single digit
Improvement in performance can be
significant
so Cara what what what is the science
the idea here is that you're stimulating
these neuronal networks that you've
already got in your brain for an hour
after wearing the headset your neurons
are a little bit more plastic so then
they would go out and practice during
that hour and the idea is that they're
going to strengthen those connections as
they're practicing so it just gives the
practice you're already doing a little
bit of a boost interesting yeah
interesting would you ever do it drew
anything to improve the vertical job
absolutely
got to be able to battle my kids here
you know
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
thought the pointing thumb and finger
game was hard try this one saw fast with
your right hand and Hammer fast with
your left hand
it's impossible it's another great
example of bimanual interference that's
the confusion your brain encounters when
your hands must each perform different
movements or the same movement with
different timing
all right now try this one draw a square
with one hand and a circle with the
other here we go okay
they're squares wait
let's start one and then let's
no no
I don't have it
[Music]
with the help of New Orleans Saints Star
Quarterback Drew Brees we're exploring
what our brains have in common with
those of extraordinary athletes we've
seen how quickly Drew was able to adapt
and react but how does anticipation fit
into decision making let's play a game
watch this player shooting a free throw
is he going to make it or miss it
science says you're more likely to guess
correctly if you're a basketball star
yourself and even crazier you probably
made your decision before the ball left
the shooter's hand how is that possible
mirror neurons those are the neurons
that fire in our brain when we watch
someone perform an action like shooting
a free throw or executing a dance step
or even giving a high five it's kind of
like muscle memory but in your brain we
all have mirror neurons but top Hoops
players have spent hours at the free
throw line giving them a huge advantage
in the anticipation department and
allowing them to mirror the shooter with
amazing Precision down to the movement
of a pinky okay I've left you hanging
long enough let's see if you're right
yes and it counts
all right all right so far on today's
brain games we have just been breaking
stuff with balls so
it's been so much fun but we've got
another game now this one will test your
ability to pay attention to many things
at once which is perfect for you because
you always have to pay attention to
everything that's going on on the
football field audience you can play
along with this one as well we're about
to test the theory that training your
brain can improve mental performance in
the same way that weightlifting can
build muscle strength in this game
you'll have to track several objects in
motion
if you happen to be an air traffic
controller or a parent watching your
kids at a busy playground you might do
well at this game let's see how you
stack up against eagle-eyed Super Bowl
quarterback Drew Brees
here are two footballs your job is to
track them as they move but we're going
to add a bunch of other footballs okay
okay here we go take a look
[Music]
okay all right and you locate the
original two footballs Drew what do you
think nine and ten nine and ten oh nine
it's wow oh okay do you want to take any
time to think one time
Drew would you like nine to ten okay now
all right
let's take a look and see if it's nine
and ten
nine and ten
ten nine and ten
to tell us what this tests and why Drew
is likely to be better at it than most
of us we've asked our Pals at Muppet
labs for a little bit of assistance
hello Keegan the task of following
multiple fast-moving objects
simultaneously is a test of several
brain functions at once vision and
perception as well as spatial awareness
concentration and working memory
researchers have consistently found
high-level athletes do especially well
at tasks like this
touchdown
Dr Bunsen Honeydew just said my name
we've made it
clip art and footballs on a giant video
screen are one thing but in order to
take this to another level we're gonna
need people in panda costumes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it is time for the experiment we call
Panda Shuffle
clearly those footballs were too easy so
now we're gonna
really tough on Drew this time he'll
have to track three different things
instead of two and by things of course I
mean dancing pandas three of our ten
pandas are wearing blue headbands and
those are the pandas that Drew will have
to track and you can play along fun fact
they do this exact drill at NFL Training
Camps okay they don't really but they
should
pandas show us your headbands please
okay okay
so Drew you see those three guys over
there with the blue headbands yes those
are the Three Pandas we need you to keep
track of all right all right the Three
Pandas with the blue headbands you ready
ready okay pandas on with their heads
see what I did there
and now Shuffle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
freaking stuff with balls
now we got pandas dancing I love it this
is great all right guys the album will
be out later tonight all right okay
pandas show us your numbers
audience did you follow that don't say
anything yet don't say anything yet did
you follow it
the girl said no okay
Drew uh so Drew I'm here's I'm I'm going
I don't know I'm going with
three and eleven I don't
there's only 10 pandas exactly yeah
that's why I'm not a quarterback okay
okay Drew uh which are the pandas with
the blue headbands all right I know for
sure five and ten five and ten okay I
think I lost my third but I'm gonna say
number one
five ten and one
show me five please
yeah
please can you show me ten
and your last one Drew uh I just guessed
I guessed one you just guessed one yeah
show me one
[Applause]
[Music]
you have another guess
another guess anything else uh yeah
I'm gonna go with six
show us number six
[Applause]
[Music]
come on great show pandas thank you
pandas
you're amazing
[Applause]
that's a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
here is another test that involves
paying attention to a bunch of things at
once
as we've seen the ability to focus is
critical to Performance can you see all
12 black dots in this grid I'm gonna bet
you can't and we'll tell you why after
this
[Applause]
[Music]
before the break we showed you this grid
with 12 black dots and asked how many of
them you could see if you could only
spot a couple you're not alone while
we're focusing on a DOT or two we
automatically replace the others with
the gray grid because our brain
considers the grid the more important
part of the picture
the same thing happens when you're
driving since your brain can't possibly
take in every detail in front of you it
focuses on the most crucial ones such as
a pedestrian about to stroll into your
path versus a billboard
[Applause]
recent evidence that Drew's brain has
enhanced decision-making abilities but
let's see what happens when his skills
are put to the test by our own Master
Mentalist lior Sousa
lior sushard has wild crowds around the
world with his amazing mental Powers
Kenny influence a Super Bowl MVP's next
big play
all right
so you know this act is very very
special because this is nothing to do
with speed nothing to do with being fast
it's about making decisions so it's a
very very simple game we prepared seven
targets for you and you're gonna have
five throws in every throw you're gonna
select one of them you can select one
twice or three I don't know this is only
your choice and your choice only are you
ready yes look at the targets
one of the targets one two seven okay
ready
set
go
okay three
okay
why three because just because because
just because okay all right you can
replace it just in case he wants to go
back to three
all right okay all right Leora are you
ready ready one through seven look at me
look at the targets one through seven
throw number two
ready
Set Go
okay
that was a good one
that was a good one just gonna put the
number two up here out the tally board
all right
so far here at the Telethon we've made
32 dollars
keep those calls coming ladies and
gentlemen
look at me look at me
look at the targets wait a minute look
at me again hi
okay it's fine and throw number three
ready
Set Go
oh wait a minute
wait a minute
okay okay okay thank you ladies and
gentlemen for keeping those calls coming
we've now made a grand total of 322
dollars
look over there somewhere one two seven
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
a Ready Set Go
foreign
last one
I can't imagine how you guys have been
doing it the generosity is amazing three
thousand two hundred twenty seven
dollars for the board ladies and
gentlemen thank you so much for calling
it okay
last round uh oh fifth throw look at me
uh oh one through seven one through
seven one through seven one through
seven wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait one two three four five six seven
wait Ready Set Go
foreign
[Applause]
tell me something how old are you I am
48 years of age what is your birthday oh
well my birthday would be March 22nd
1970 freaking one
laughs
and you want to tell me what happened
this is what happened Drew every time he
said set he'd say Ready Set he'd write a
number and then you'd throw it at that
number
every single time
and it happened to me my birthday
ladies and gentlemen unbelievable
thank you
NFL prospects all take a cognitive
abilities quiz filled with brain testers
like this
which shape below is a mirror image of
the one at the top that's been rotated
180 degrees
[Applause]
[Music]
we asked you to figure out which shape
below can be made by taking the mirror
image of the top shape and rotating it
180 degrees if you chose B you're one
step closer to your NFL dream
oh oh I got all right here I'm gonna get
you right in the aisle
there you go legendary NFL quarterback
Drew Brees epitomizes practice makes
perfect he's great at making quick
decisions and tracking fast-moving
objects with amazing accuracy
now Cara Santa Maria is back with
another interesting way the brain can be
trained to improve performance
so
so Drew we heard that you were a fan of
spear fishing and that there is one
aspect of it that you really really wish
you could improve upon what is that well
obviously when you're diving down there
sometimes you got to hang out for a
while right wait for the right
opportunity so I wish I could hold my
breath for a bit longer ah okay
interesting that's very interesting oh
oh hello Cara hey
how are you
I I had no idea you were here yeah um
it's quite convenient it's very much so
Kara can you tell Drew and the rest of
us what you've been up to and why you're
in this tank absolutely so I have been
interested in kind of pushing my limits
for a while and I am not an athlete by
any stretch of the imagination I wanted
to see if something that I thought was
impossible would be possible which is to
hold my breath longer than I don't know
30 seconds okay so I've been training up
for it really yeah okay well let's take
a look yeah all right
foreign
athletes in the world owe their
Competitive Edge to this man Dr Andy
Walsh is an expert in Elite human
performance
[Music]
he advises Olympic skiers and
snowboarders big wave Surfers
competitive cyclists and regular people
like me wow look at this space I'm
meeting him at this high performance lab
in Santa Monica California where
athletes learn how to hack their brains
and up their game when I think of
training performers I think of training
the body one of the most powerful tools
we have is actually train the mind to
perform when things really count how do
you train the mind training for the mind
is really just learning about how the
brain responds when it's put under
stress and that's a lot more to do with
what's up here than it is to do with the
body to test out Andy's methods I'm
joined by Hannah Bowen and Lou hack who
want to improve their ability to hold
their breath big breath in
and hold Hannah is a former
Intercollegiate swimmer and Lou is a
former military search and rescue diver
my Baseline is 47 seconds Hannah's is 53
seconds and lose is 60 Seconds
learning to control and slow down
breathing can open up higher levels of
performance
the breathe up technique which involves
filling your lungs several times with
air deepens breathing and slows down
your heart rate allowing you to retain
more oxygen the whole point is to be
more in control of your body and mind
and the best part is with the proper
training anyone can do it
and as Hannah and Lou work through the
exercises their ability to hold their
breath increases by the time they're
done Hannah has her time up to two
minutes and 35 seconds and Lou is all
the way up to 3 minutes and 35 seconds
good to go yeah good to go all right
okay let's start that breathe up now
honestly I don't think I can make it up
to a minute your breasts nothing easy
but that's the entire point of the
exercise and haul we're going for one
minute nice relax gaining control of my
body and pushing my own limits slit your
arms go let your body go nice and easy
three
two
one lift your head up and breathe
there's no doubt Andy's techniques work
I've already increased my performance by
13 seconds and the more I do it the more
confident I feel
I've hacked my brain and now I can do
something I never thought I could good
good job fantastic
amazing
it's amazing Carol
so let's bring out Andy Walsh ladies and
gentlemen her trainer here
so Andy and Kara uh tell us what's about
to happen right now
well she's gotta do a little breathe up
here just to get herself in the right
headspace and then she's just gonna hold
her breath and we'll see how far she can
go simple as that all right all right so
now Drew if you if you want in on this
we may have an extra yeah it's as simple
as that I I uh I'll let her do it it
might be a little tight but water
overflows oh yeah yeah we don't want
that no no not all over the stage it
would be a lot of cleanup no I get
hooked on with you I'm with you I'll
just observe okay all right okay okay so
Cara the clock is set
when you're ready
so Andy why is Jurgen in the tank what
what is Jurgen providing for Kara here
number one job is safety making sure
that she feels like someone's supporting
her that she has someone's got her back
that helps her relax a little more and
also if she sort of starts to run out of
breath he can support her and bring her
up and make sure she doesn't push
herself too far and maybe make it
dangerous
she's trying to calm herself right now
and what's really happening is she's not
running out of oxygen but the CO2 in her
body is starting to build up so he
actually has quite a lot of oxygen to go
for quite some time but the CO2 is going
to try and Trigger her to breathe and
she has to relax as that urge to breathe
comes on and as she relaxes more the
longer she can hold her breath she
actually has enough oxygen to go for the
world record is about 12 minutes for
this sort of breath oh my goodness 12
minutes yeah
that's a minute
so and then eventually you get to a
place where there's so much CO2 that you
wouldn't be able to hold your breath the
CO2 will trigger a center in your brain
the brain's going to say look you've got
to breathe is there any other way that
these techniques can help an elite
athlete like Drew what would the other
applications be applications really
simple you've got a challenge in front
of you which you don't know how far you
can improve against the challenge puts
you in that state of being a little
anxious learning how to overcome that
challenge in a relatively safe
environment like this teaches you the
techniques and tools that you can then
take to your other field of endeavor
that's a minute 30. as you get in a
position where you're you're moving a
lot like if you're diving and you're
having to maneuver underwater obviously
that's that's another element that takes
place and and how you call them yourself
at the same time right yeah so in that
underwater scenario you're gonna go
about half as long as you could doing
this but then you've got to keep those
movements slow and relaxed right at the
end of the day it's about calming your
your mind and body right
um which is going to maximize your
ability to hold your breath
that's two minutes
you blew your old record out of the
water
Harrison Santa Maria
[Applause]
how do you feel
out of breath okay
it's not easy yeah you know it feels
like you're going to die but what I've
learned throughout this process is that
um you're not like you you can actually
live for a little bit longer without
oxygen or with that much CO2 in your
lungs but your brain tells you to panic
so much of this is about getting in the
right head space to sort of hack your
brain and override that it's all about
being Zen and really meditating
um so really I mean you don't have to be
an athlete to to improve your breath
hold you've just really got to gain a
lot of control over your own mind wow
[Applause]
and Andy Walsh
ladies and gentlemen amazing
extraordinary
[Applause]
[Music]
you'll want to pay attention to this
next game because that's exactly what
we'll be testing your ability to pay
attention scientists have found that our
brain has a limited amount of resources
it can allocate to focusing on any one
item at a time when we shift from one
thing to another there is a slight Gap
in our attention span that experts call
an attentional link don't believe me try
this I'm going to show you a series of
letters in Rapid succession your job is
to spot the letter that comes
immediately after the W ready
what letter did you see after the W
the answer
it was F if you're like most people you
saw the W but not the f because your
brain was still busy processing the fact
that you spotted the W when the F was by
even though we told your brain it was
coming your brain blinked and missed it
I am here with legendary NFL quarterback
Drew Brees who's already proven he's
better than most of us at things like
decision making focus and Grace Under
Pressure now it's time for him to put it
all together and more for the gauntlet
foreign
each week our celebrity guests play the
same series of games designed to test
their balance perception and focus let's
see how Drew Brees performs in our
complex and confusing collection of
brain games
it all starts with balance on my Mark
you are going to pour water from this
pitcher into that glass you're going to
have 15 seconds you're going to try to
get as much in there as you possibly can
goat
s all right all right that is oh God
that is hard all right station two okay
reception
keep your eyes on Tim Allen and tell us
what you hear
[Music]
he's generating a lot of Buzz he's
generating a lot of fuzz
incorrect next video
there's a fly in my gutter
there's a flying by something
okay we'll move on to the next one go to
the next one
that's a double
that's a double
satisfactory
it's a tough one
station three okay intuition it is you
against leor three games of rock paper
scissors you only have to beat him one
time all right round one ready go one
two three oh that's a tie that's a tie
that's a tie I only gotta beat up once
round two go one two three oh that's a
tie
you're a one game away Drew here we go
all right rock this out round three
ready go one two three
all right
this is mental processing you're going
to match the color of the letters on the
ball with the name of that color on the
bin all right at some point you're going
to hear this
then the names on the bins will change
we're going to stand over here by the
shoot when I hand you the first ball we
put 30 seconds on the clock and
begin
thank you
five four three two one and we're done
[Laughter]
finally maintaining composure you're
going to stand here you're going to hold
this tray and balance these glasses okay
okay
here we are in whatever manner you see
fit balance the glasses beautiful now
Drew you're going to look at that camera
right there and all you have to do just
stare at that camera and keep your cool
that's the only thing you have to do
okay
so I'll let you uh
do your thing
oh nice nice eyes
oh no are you what are you kidding me
the air horn doesn't work
the air horn doesn't work again
[Laughter]
you're a competitive guy how was the
experience for you uh the entire
experience was was awesome you know just
the pouring the water into the glass
while you're getting tossed around a
little bit that's uh yeah you enjoyed
that yeah yeah yeah
this was great you were great at this
that was tough I'm still wondering what
happened with that here's what happened
it's very deceptive it seems like it's
gonna be simple he's generating a lot of
Buzz their mouths are saying one thing
and what you're hearing is something
different they're super similar I feel
like I learned a lot today you did yeah
you did great so
what do we learned tonight
when it comes to the world's top
athletes their physical abilities will
only take them so far and the highest
levels of competition The Athlete's
brain is as important as their body
breaking stuff with footballs is Fun
making stuff with balls is fun
Drew Brees can track a panda like
nobody's business
and to paraphrase Yogi Berra 90 of the
game is half mental I would like to
thank Dr Andy Walsh and our special
guest NFL legend Drew Brees
all right
[Applause]
we got the uh we got the dirt ball out
here now all right here we go
[Applause]
[Music]